welcome to hannity uh we have a lot
coming up tonight roger stone will join
us with more on these pre-dawn raids in
this case at his home oh with fake news
cnn cameras how did they get tipped off
along with the very latest details from
america's partisan two-tiered system of
justice
but tonight we begin with a fox news
alert breaking right now one individual
with access to the fbi search warrant
news that mar-a-lago is revealing new
details to this show tonight about that
document and tonight we can exclusively
report that the warrant identified two
very vague categories of interest one
documents that should or could be in the
national archives and two anything else
that might be more classified it was
actually that general now mr garland
let's see the affidavit that you
presented to the trump-hating obama
loving jeffrey epstein's friends
defender
magistrate because the list of what they
took was kind of also vague and
meaningless so the affidavit what you
did to get this warrant you took
responsibility today we'd like to see it
and i said on day one that this was one
big giant fishing expedition expedition
i believe this was all a pretext and
they were looking for any and all
documents of mar-a-lago it is official
we're now fully immersed in yet another
anti-trump witch hunt now you show me
the man will find the crime now you can
accept they never ever seem to find the
crime in the case of donald trump
because one doesn't exist and by the way
what they took was meaningless seemingly
what we know now and at the same time
joe biden and his son hunter are well
they're enjoying a lavish vacation at an
exclusive island in south carolina
yesterday the father-son duo they were
all smiles as they look at hunter
boarding air force one you're paying for
it
not a single care in the world no
worries about a pre-dawn raid at his
house
despite let's see pictures videos emails
texts eyewitness accounts and a lot of
other evidence detailing a variety of
serious crimes ranging from sex
trafficking drug use illegal gun
possession money laundering tax fraud
fair violations hunter biden has never
been the subject of an fbi raid and
let's not forget all the information
that implicates his cognitive mess of a
father joe as a liar lied to the
american people i never once talked to
my son not once about his foreign
business dealing uh we now know that
that is completely false not true we
know of at least 14 maybe as many as 17
instances we even have pictures of of
hunter and his farm business partners
with joe biden that would mean that the
biden family and the biden presidency in
particular that our president could be
compromised by russia china ukraine and
other countries countries that were
paying his son with no experience a
whole lot of money it would explain
joe's preferential treatment to
countries like russia and china but the
biden's vacation it's not going to be
interrupted with any search warrant it's
not clear that hunter or joe will ever
be charged with a crime if i had to bet
they'll get away with it like the
clintons they'll get away with it you
know like every other deep state actor
you know comey mccabe strzok page
remember all those names how many people
are held accountable for lying
on a fisa application to get us a
warrant to spy on a sitting president
now we get the message in today's
america if you are a democrat you can
smoke crack on camera you can record
yourself with foreign prostitutes you
can skip out on paying your taxes and
you can even sell your country to the
highest bidder and you'll get away with
all of it you're above the law now you
can kick back you'll take in tons of
money and thanks to your vice president
father and get daddy your vp to withhold
even a billion taxpayer dollars to get
some ukrainian prosecutor fired for
investigating the millions
that uh you were paid with because you
had no experience well that's the reason
to get paid all those millions but if
you're donald trump and you comply with
the bureaucrats at the national archives
as we have letters from the national
archives from february show as we know
they met on june 3rd you still have 40
well-armed fbi agents guns drawn banging
on your front door unannounced blowing
open your brand new safe but according
to the media mob this wasn't a raid you
see this is the problem with
conservatives you thought that was a
raid this is only a routine government
approved visit from the feds take a look
the former president talking about a
raid and a break-in
that's not what happened we have to be
careful not to adopt
the term raid that was an intentional
use of a word and and you we haven't
done it all all night and a quick but i
want to say important note for our
audience we keep hearing a lot of people
call what the fbi did at mar-a-lago a
raid but for fact sake here's the deal
law enforcement doesn't even use the
term raid the only reason you'd have an
uh a search like this and let's be
polite and call it a search and not a
raid trump's describing it as a raid you
know officials i'm talking to are
pushing back on that what we know about
what played out on monday is that it
wasn't the sort of thing that you would
call a raid where fbi agents go in guns
blazing knocking on doors yelling this
is not an unauthorized raid it was a
search conducted pursuant to a lawfully
well authorized warrant the fact is that
this was a very orderly
search of the property was not a raid
it was a raid this is the same media
that spread hillary rodham clinton's
russian dossier and the same media that
lied and sent hunter's laptop that's
russian disinformation the same media
that lies again and again and again and
they don't stop it wasn't really a raid
really and according to joe biden's
attorney general merrick garland the
administration cares so deeply about
equal application of our laws oh okay
then i guess hunter and joe are going to
expect a visit in the early morning
hours in kiawah in south carolina this
weekend take a look
faithful adherence to the rule of law is
the bedrock principle of the justice
department and of our democracy
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly
without fear or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing
all americans are tight entitled to the
even-handed application of the law
to due process of the law
and to the presumption of innocence
yeah well you've had hundreds laptop for
almost two years actions speak louder
than words i think you're a lying
hypocrite obama took 30 million pages of
sensitive potentially classified
presidential material to chicago not one
page has ever been returned where's the
rate of obama's house bill clinton took
a ton of items from the white house when
he left one of his top aides even tried
to steal classified material from the
national archives went into the national
archives shoved it down his pants and in
his socks
where's the raid on bill clinton's house
his wife hillary as you all know stored
thousands and thousands of government
emails and classified documents on
private servers that were hacked by
outside forces where's the raid on her
house in chappaqua wherever they happen
to live apparently charging hillary with
a crime was unthinkable according to jim
comey your former fbi director good old
jim superior jim take a look
case given the importance of the matter
i think unusual transparency is in order
although there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
no
she broke the law but no reasonable
prosecutor why let the prosecutor decide
for themselves keep in mind and this is
important unlike hillary clinton who
tried to destroy evidence donald trump
was complying with federal officials
prior to the raid and he already handed
over multiple boxes as many as 15
and as of june 3rd the fbi and doj they
were at mar-a-lago the national archives
noted his cooperation in a statement
back in february the former president
met with these federal officials from
the doj
and other agencies in june he showed
them the rest of the documents they
asked them to put a padlock on the door
securing the documents at their request
and he also said come back for whatever
you need anytime you need to but because
his last name is donald trump not biden
not obama not clinton not hunter it just
wasn't enough so the fbi went judge
shopping they found the perfect guy a
compromised obama donor trump hater on
social media to rubber stamp their
absurd warrant and then rolled up at
mar-a-lago in force and now according to
my sources despite demands from the fbi
to turn all the security cameras at the
residence off apparently those cameras
kept rolling now those who have seen the
footage tell us that the fbi did not act
in good faith apparently agents went
room to room many had guns drawn
scouring anything and everything in
sight and they even searched rooms not
listed on the warrant why were they
going through melania's pockets of
her wardrobe make no mistake if and when
we get this footage we'll show it to you
in full and let you decide the fbi
doesn't want anyone to see it apparently
they want all the copies for themselves
they're attempting to seize these
recordings and cover their tracks and
today merrick garland provided few
details about the search he took no
questions that he should have taken but
he vehemently defended the doj and the
fbi take a look
let me address recent unfounded attacks
on the professionalism of the fbi and
justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
the men and women of the fbi and the
justice department are dedicated
patriotic public servants
every day they protect the american
people from violent crime
terrorism and other threats to their
safety
while safeguarding our civil rights
they do so at great personal sacrifice
and risk to themselves
i am honored to work alongside them
i agree 95 of fbi agents they are good
honest hard-working
members of the law enforcement community
i agree that all officers deserve to be
safe and protected bad apples need to be
fired and or indicted there is never any
reason for any violence against any law
enforcement officer ever under any
circumstances it could never be
tolerated as we said repeatedly in the
summer of 2020 i don't remember many
democrats doing that okama laharis was
supporting them and many democrats were
either silent or complicit
giving out you know bail fund addresses
etc merrick garland let me give you some
reasons why no one trusts your
department or the fbi when it comes to
donald trump your fbi your doj illegally
obtained fisa warrants and three
separate renewals to spy on the trump
campaign the trump transition team and
trump as president and you used his
opponent hillary clinton's dirty bought
and paid for russian dossier as evidence
and lied to a fisa court judge and said
it was verified and we know it's
unverifiable doj official bruce ohr
warned that the dossier was garbage back
in august of 2016. he said it was
unsourced unverifiable russian
disinformation put together by an
ex-foreign spy at the request of the
clinton campaign you were warned ahead
of time the ex-foreign spy christopher
steele even noted under oath that the
material in the dossier was unverifiable
but the fbi and doj didn't care and none
of those people were held accountable
next they went on a two-year partisan
witch hunt led by devout democrat andrew
weissman and staff with clinton donors
director ray never held one of those
people accountable he made no
institutional changes no reforms at all
and this is where we are today and
that's why people don't trust this one
once great uh law institution and that
is the fbi the justice department by the
way just labeled concerned parents
speaking out at school board meetings as
potential domestic terrorists that may
need to be investigated at the request
of the democrats they have also
seemingly ignored the dozens of attacks
on pro-life
pregnancy centers they declined to
prosecute violent far-left rioters who
attacked federal buildings in the summer
of 2020
that courthouse in portland thousands of
cops injured dozens of americans dead
they did nothing to stop the doxing and
harassment of supreme court justices
even though we have a law against that
prohibiting that they barely yawn when
chuck schumer threatened these same
justices by name on the steps of the u.s
supreme court they couldn't care less
when kamala harris promoted that bail
fund to get riders out of jail and and
told them not to to stop writing take
note they're not going to stop they
won't stop they shouldn't stop we won't
stop and now they don't seem to care at
all that the disgusting frankly biden
family literally sold access to the
highest levels of the us government
china russia ukraine kazakhstan attorney
general garland you've had hunter's
laptop for two years you talk about
equal justice equal application of our
laws where is it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else